welcome back to Petersburg nonsense in
the last couple of hours Johnny Depp has
hit the red carpet of the Cannes Film
Festival as his new film Jean DeBerry
opens the event
this is him on the red carpet you can
hear at the end of this
cheer for Johnny
and he got shared when he went inside
the auditorium but it's been an outcry
from Amber Heard supporters and some
French actresses with the hashtag can
you not accusing the film festival of
celebrating abuses for 76 years now
Johnny Depp was Vindicated at his recent
trial in America with Amber Heard
ordered to pay him 10 million dollars
and basically exposed as a liar so does
Johnny Depp have the right to relaunch
his career or is Hollywood being
hypocritical by celebrating someone
who'd even been accused of such behavior
and of course lost a libel case in the
UK we're joining me now is Nick Wallace
author of debt be heard the unreal story
and the family law Barrister Paula Roan
Adrian okay Nick it's an interesting
thing Johnny Depp welcomed like a movie
star as he has been since he won this
case in America been mobbed but he
doesn't have a completely clean slate
because he lost the liberal action in
the UK a judge ruled that the son
basically by calling him a wife beater
that they were entitled to do that so
it's messy and there's no doubt that
this relationship with Amber Heard was
extremely mutually toxic and abusive it
just comes down to how you categorize
who was more to blame and what the abuse
was like which I think your book does it
in a lot of detail
I think the point about Johnny Depp
tonight is should he be continued to be
fated as a blemish-free movie star in
the way we're seeing at the cam Film
Festival well I'm sure he would say he
had the right to do that having got the
verdict that he did in Virginia and this
huge wave of public support that
followed it all the way up to but what
about the other verdict in London well
this is always going to be the fly in
the ointment Mr Justice nickel a learned
respected judge spent three months
looking over the transcripts the
evidence and all the contemporaneous
documentary evidence which he which he
did place a huge amount of weight on and
after three months he decided he came
down very firmly in favor of the sun
yeah Amber Heard was the star witness in
that trial he essentially believed what
she had to say and ruled that on 12
separate occasions Johnny Depp did
physically so where does that leave
where does that leave him in the in the
court of public opinion you've got to
say Johnny Depp appears to pretty well
be unanimously the winner well he is the
winner but as you know it's all about
the money isn't it and this has now come
out of the courts and is now in the
hands of the Hollywood Studios Johnny
Depp has been on this incredibly
well-managed Rehabilitation Arc since
last year he went on tour with Jeff Beck
was mobbed everywhere he went he all
just gave him a 20 million dollar
contract his highest ever for a man with
a fragrance he's co-producing a movie
with Al Pacino this is a really
important step on his own Rehabilitation
opening the Cannes Film Festival he's
got European Movie Makers behind him
standing ovation in the theater what he
needs now is to get to Hollywood he
needs Disney to say okay you can have a
lead part or a bit part in the next
Pirates movie should should Hollywood or
a firm like Disney do that with Johnny
Depp does he deserve to be brought back
I mean the hypocrisy of the cam Film
Festival it's an incredibly glamorous
event I've covered it many times myself
but they fated people like Roman
Polanski who's a fugitive child rapist
who escaped Justice for what he did so
they've got a long history of tolerating
this kind of thing they do say some of
the festival organizers they prefer to
celebrate the Arts rather than the
person which is an easy get out but some
people do think that
um where do we stand with Johnny Depp
celebrating the art and not the person I
would accept that if it was Amber Heard
who was on the red carpet I would accept
that
um I would accept that that we were
celebrating the art and not the person
if it was Amber Heard who hadn't lost
her L'Oreal contract I would accept that
that we were celebrating the art not the
person if Amber Heard wasn't hounded by
4.5 million people to sign a contract so
that she didn't get to partake in the
Aquaman 2 role but we're not celebrating
the Arts we clearly are celebrating the
person and this is what concerns me
particularly when we know that two women
a week die because of abuse from their
Partners
an American court trial determined at
the end of it that they didn't believe
it that she was a liar it is clouded by
what happened in London no question but
the most recent test of the veracity of
both of their claims about what went on
that marriage was an unequivocal win for
Johnny Depp and he has taken that as you
would understand the two to one wasn't
it it was a two to one but he won so it
you know in terms of the finances he
came out better of course than Amber did
what amber wanted was that unequivocal
win the same win that she was able to
obtain but she didn't get it on behalf
of the Sun and she didn't get it so why
shouldn't you be allowed to continue
with his career as I I haven't said he
shouldn't be allowed to continue with
his career what I'm concerned about is
the fact that they're not being treated
equally and what we have is a society
who seems to accept that it's okay for a
man to be an abuser but it's not okay
for a woman they have both uh sent out
they sent out a joint statement to
suggest that the relationship was
volatile they accepted that this is when
the marriage was settled but then went
out of her way to become a spokesperson
for gender-based violence right based on
her relationship with Johnny Depp and
that is the point at which Johnny Depp
said well hang on a minute and why was
she wrong to do that why was she wrong
to identify that she believed that she
was a victim of domestic
hang on stop painting her as some kind
of Angel Amber herb was not an angel
from what everything I saw did some
terrible acts of abuse both physical
verbal we saw it we heard it we heard
the evidence we saw the pictures and so
on she's not an angel in this right the
question is I think
when you get a situation that's messy
like this what happens to the main
people involved right and you might be
right there has been a double standard
Johnny Depp and I've got the pictures
now inside the auditorium at the Canton
Festival of this Standing Ovation got
listen to some of this my when one of
the first uh strong pictures hand in
hand
unequivocal emphatic voter support from
the movie industry this is about money I
mean it's a huge snub to Amber hurt yeah
Amber Heard don't forget is the only
person in this couple at the moment
who's got a big Hollywood movie from
everything you've read is in Aquaman
you've researched them better than most
people in this fascinating book
from everything you've gleaned here
where does the truth lie do you think
well one thing that I have learned from
studying this case and Reporting on both
of them on the ground is that no one has
a monopoly on trees not a high court
judge not Johnny Depp not Amber not
seven well this is this is where you get
right into the culture War because there
is an argument on I would say the
feminist side that can only be one
abuser in a relationship the concept of
mutual abuse which came up in the
Virginia trial is something that I don't
know whether colleagues of yours would
say does not exist because it allows
abusers to say ah you're abusing me
you're the problem in this relationship
and it can turn things on its head so we
have a real issue where people say of
course you can have mutual abuse in a
relationship Amber Heard admitted to
physically hitting Johnny Depp on a
number of occasions but does that make
her an abuser or does that make her
someone responding you know what I
reacting my takeaway for at the end of
it was they had a highly toxic alcohol
and drug-fueled relationship which
spilled over into verbal and physical
violence right and this went on for
quite a long time and actually they are
both I wouldn't say equally because I
wasn't there I don't know but they both
certainly contributed to the blame of
the breakdown of this relationship with
their behavior and so I don't see two
angels
um but I'm not quite sure where the
scales lie given we've now had two court
cases one complete exoneration
effectively for debt and the other one
the opposite yes and and and and that
sounds very reasonable sitting here in
the studio but what's the message that's
been sent to victims of abuse the
message that's been sent to victims of
abuse particularly women is don't speak
out if your man is rich and Powerful or
if you're lying that's the message or if
you're lying well in this country it's
not in America it was determined she
lied right so this is this is where it
gets more complicated you have a
Hollywood star Amber Heard who plays the
victim tries to cash in on being a
victim right op-ed pieces in serious
newspapers and does all that stuff
promoting herself promoting her brand as
a mouth shut peers I'm not saying that
could she have kept her mouth I'm not
saying that you're not her voice is gone
no no but your argument that we should
despite that she spoke out no no but
well she's entitled to absolutely but
then she's also Johnny Depp is entitled
to defend himself and he didn't win the
case
I don't think she represents taken aside
I don't think she represents your
average Joe victim in the street so I
think drawing that parallel to me is
wrong who is that Average Joe this is
exactly the problem we have a
preconceived view of what an abuser
looks like and having that preconceived
view means that we then challenge a
person when they come forward when they
speak out we say no you can't be the one
who suffered because you look like this
now you can't be the one who suffered
you're wearing a short story you can't
be the one who suffered because you were
drinking alcohol I don't want to
interrupt you but I'm going to interrupt
you
uh to say this I recently interviewed a
young man who'd been part of this
appalling case up north where a woman
fantasist yes had assaulted herself yes
and then blamed a bunch of innocent men
and this guy went to prison for several
months and was facing 20 years in in
prison but eventually she got exposed
right I don't believe in always
believing people or categorizing
everyone who comes forward right as a
victim well there's an automatic you are
you are clearly telling the truth I
believe in respecting people in
listening to them and examining the
facts and see where that takes you
because otherwise you're going to get
fantasies and people if that was correct
peers if our society was built on that
fairness then we wouldn't have had
Rochdale we wouldn't have had Rochester
we wouldn't have had the low stats that
we know exist in terms of reporting
Amber Heard came out with what she said
she was believed Johnny Depp's career
went into a tailspin and as far as he
was said he was an innocent wronged man
and so he went to court to restore his
reputation which he has a right to do
and we know how it panned out it panned
out with a lot of cognitive dissonance
because we're trying to work out how a
British jurisdiction can say yes he is
an abuser and a wife-beater and how the
American public and an American Jury can
say no absolutely not she was the liar
in all of this which is what the
fascination about this story is but when
she came out saying I was abused by
Johnny Depp his only recourse is through
the courts because he he couldn't do it
any other way and otherwise his entire
career was gone and his entire career
could have gone if you believe the
American
trial because of a liar so it's but it
is complicated I'm not saying for a
moment he's blameless I'm just saying
that I don't and exactly that but I
don't think she I don't think she is a
great standard Bearer for victims of
domestic violence given that she herself
was so violent well that's where I'm
sorry I don't but but also why why is it
that the canned jury had decided to
really push this film to put it in the
prestigious opening slot this is not
okay Johnny Depp's got a right to work
but let's just hold our nose and get
well the answer is look at the film
industry what's it interested in bums on
seats and money yeah it's not there to
make anymore the fact that Roman
Polanski still gets standing ovations or
and the first one was led at the Oscars
In Absentia after he absconded from
America to avoid Justice for raping an
underage girl and that's what he did I
mean the facts aren't contested and he
escaped Justice and escaped Justice for
50 years he is still lorded around the
world including in Hollywood as some
kind of hero I mean it's it is a morally
bankrupt industry when it comes to these
kind of things anyway uh this is a
morally unbankrant book uh debt we heard
the unreal Story by Nick well it's
fascinating read uh it's an
extraordinary story I know people who
know Johnny who absolutely love him I
know people who know Johnny Depp and say
yeah it doesn't surprise me I'll know
the same with Amber Heard I have no idea
Amber who's had to run away and hide
beneath the stone in Madrid somewhere
not Johnny he's allowed on a red carpet
all right we're going to leave it there